so okay so here we have six years old
captain's open shoes month going to go
with 14 years and four months let's see
did I really play like this at 14 years
old I don't know maybe I did oh [ __ ]
we're going to have it's Irish I don't
like this at all - 14 9 4 months out is
coming to treat me today
just come into tricky big time so I'm
going to play a line that was not known
at the time of my name is 14 apparently
he does [ __ ] it's going to be yet
another embarrassment okay I'm going to
change hands
yet another how many failures okay well
I cannot say that mine is 14 years old
and four months old which is something I
love saying is during this turbulent
brilliantly but we'll see what happens
I'm definitely as I said definitely
slightly better okay let's try and load
up on on that part he is going to trick
me he's going to treat me maybe I should
speak up
I have such a nice positional advantage
but I don't know what to do about it
yeah let's try and reroute the night
okay so now if this works that would be
nice so now I'm calculating Knight to f4
Bishop a4 rook c5 Bishop d1 rook d5
Bishop g4 9 h5 that does seem to work
let's see if it does ha ha I did he
didn't have Bishop a4 that was a boost
of confidence if I ever had one Wow
ah there is video so you can actually
see my my expression wow wow wow that
was very unpleasant Wow
I did not anticipate that okay so let's
if I try to pretend to be calm okay
let's go Queen d2 Bishop i-4 are you
kidding me - 14 years old and 14 months
turns out to be quite the unpleasant
beasts
okay let's try B for now I'm definitely
losing the thread tactically but what
can you do okay rook c5 rook F for Wow
can this really work this is utterly
shocking I am now officially mortified
okay so if I cover up t5 work to 5f III
Queen III maybe has rook F to all the
tricky minuses this may turn out to be
the trickiest yet okay I'm trying to
calculate Bishop c6 that's definitely
over the top but why does it not work
quickly focus
okay let's I cannot find anything better
than this I know what is I fee maybe
Lucas Richie for is good then Bishop s7
make sure if that works though
okay let's try a sphere look if I'm
Brooke chase three so I'm certainly
missing something I'm just trying to
find out whether this Queen periods
Bishop episode
okay floor I don't see anything else
worked you for nf2
Oh
he's threatening something yeah you are
you okay give up the game it says watch
out yeah I know I have to watch out
amulet I'm probably losing her
okay last hope is to try and set up a
fortress stupid idiot goes for the pawn
of course it does
now this may be a draw it is a very
unpleasant way to make it so I'm not
going to take on g6 cause the queen of
seven can see that stress threat nice
Queen maybe it doesn't see it come on do
something
come on play g5 whatever just something
huh never going to play with - 14 years
old in 14 months again she is a most
unpleasant person h5 well sort of makes
sense now he's going to try and play g5
some point and I'm not sure I can do too
much about it I'm just going to sit here
don't I have better ways to spend my
time than this okay now I yeah now I
dropped a rock on the wrong square now I
don't want to do I really wanted this
game to be over with
stupid - I hate you okay that's enough
for today